في غضون ذلك اصدرت اربعه احزاب سياسيه
بيانا تعلن فيه دعمها لتحركات الصحفيين
كانت احزاب التيار والتكتل والقطب والعمال
ما سمته محاولات سلطه الانقلاب تدجين
الاعلام كما مددت بما وصفته بتجويع
الصحفيين وتحويل التلفزه الوطنيه العموميه
الى بوق رديء للديكتاتوريه واعتبرت ذلك
جزءا من تحكم السلطه الانقلاب بوثاق
الحقوق والحريات اضاف البيان وان معركه
حريه الاعلام جزء لا يتجزا من معركه الشعب
لوضع حد نهائي لما وصفته بالانقلاب
والاستبداد والديكتاتوريه
ينضم الينا من تونس مراسل الجزيره سيف
الدين بوعلاق سيف الدين مرحبا بك معنا اذا
ما يعني طبيعه هذه الاستدعاءات للاستماع
الى محامين وايضا ان كانت هنالك صفه لهذه
المجموعه المستدعاه من المحامي
بالفعل محمد ما رشح من معلومات الى حد
الان 14 محاميا تتعلق قضيتهم او استدعاء
للتحقيق بما حدث في العام الماضي عندما تم
ايقاف
النائب رئيس حركه النهضه والمحامي نور
الدين البحيري ثم وضع قائد الاقامه
الجبريه ونقل الى احد المراكز الامنيه في
محافظه بنزرت شماليه تونس ومن ثم حدثت
مناوشات ونقاشات حاده بين المحامين وبين
عدد من رجال الامن وهو ما تحركت هذه
القضيه خلال هذه الايام وتم طبعا هناك
اجراء خاص بالمحامين على بخلاف المدنيين
يتم توجيه الاستدعاء ليس للمحامي بشكل
مباشر وانما لفرع المحاماه وبالتالي فرع
المحاماه في تونس هو من اصدر او نشر هذه
معلومه واعلمه المحامين بمساله التحقيق في
هذه القضيه تحديدا
والمعنيين بهذه القضيه هم
ابرزهم عميد المحامين السابق عبد الرزاق
الكيلاني وايضا سمير الجيل والقياده
الخلاص الوطني واناث الحرات التي تنوبه
عددا من المحامين المعارضين المحامين
وايضا نشطاء وسياسيين ونقابيين في علاقه
نشاطهم السياسي ومواقفها مما يصفونه
بانقلاب الرئيس قيس سعيد هذه ما يتعلق
بقطاع المحاماه الذي تحرك في اكثر من
مناسبه في الحقيقه خاصه فيما يتعلق
بملاحقه المحامين والحكم عليهم في قضايا
امام المحاكم العسكريه وبالتالي قطاع
المحاماه يعتبر نفسه مستهدفا بهذه الى
حالات خاصه وان القطاع المحاماه مثل ما
تعلم محمد عدد كبير منهم
نشطاء في الحقل السياسي او في المجتمع
المدني بينما في ضمن هذه الاوضاع وفي ظل
الايام الاخيره التي شهدت عده ملاحقات ضد
النشطاء ومحامين وسياسيين وقضاه وايضا
رئيس اذاعه او مدير عام اذاعه خاصه
بالتالي هناك الجو عام من الاحالات
والمحاكمات محمد نعم شكرا جزيلا لك من
تونس